i was thinking i was thinking about you
know uh guns and gun rights
and i think i realized something when
you first start buying guns and getting
into it you realize
we're totally desensitized to cars i
know cars aren't
created for the purpose of killing
people so i get that part of the left
left left argument cars are dangerous
cars kill a lot of people
very very very very often and i think
about how we walk through busy streets
you go to new york and like somebody
will just walk through a busy street as
cars are flying past them because they
know people will use their brakes
why don't they have that same level of
trust in somebody walking down the
street with a gun
that's a really good point i know and
i've seen kids
they they're like arrogantly walking the
street and the car will slow down and
start honking at them
angrily or look at the ante for people
who go around surrounding cars and
smashing them
they know no one's gonna do anything to
him yet when it comes to guns
the assumption is that like every
law-abiding citizen will just go nuts
and start shooting randomly
i think because guns are unique they're
not transport vehicles
like their only job is to fire a bullet
basically which is you basically a
killing tool it's not necessarily true
you can also consider them a deterrent
if you see somebody with a gun you're
not going to mess with them
but i i see i see your point but what
i'm saying is
don't you trust people kind of dude
sometimes i drive down the road and i'm
like whoa okay
no for two tons of metal going past each
other 120 miles an hour
calculated both 60 in each direction all
it take and we're we're just trusting
that neither one of us is gonna
it's amazing isn't it think about this
i'm driving down a west virginia road
and it's like 55 mile limit and there's
a thin yellow paint strip in the middle
of the road
to stop me in another car which is like
two feet from me from slamming in with
the full force of 110 miles an hour and
i was just
mutilating it to answer your question
yeah i trust people on
like
that's what i realized when i would like
you know walk around west virginia i see
these people with guns all the time
and i'm just like i'm not worried about
any of these people doing anything to me
because i'm not worried about
cars either so you're becoming
desensitized to it because i bet if
people had never seen a car
and they were first time they'd be
terrified yeah like ah it's coming right
for me
but since we're like two or three
they're like what look both ways at the
car i mean in the very beginning they
probably were probably terrified of the
noise
yeah the speed and i'm just you just get
used to it
it's trust me regular people are all
right but guess what
sometimes people ram cars into people
like some like we see these videos man
and there's some really awful instances
that have happened to that van thing in
europe
so we've just become so accustomed and
desensitized the fact that regular
people
just want to live their lives sometimes
people drink and drive
i think a lot of it is situational too
though when i lived in dc when i heard
gunshots i would get scared and i would
like
contemplate calling the police or going
look if there's somebody like dying
outside
when i hear gunshots in west virginia we
all say like it sounds like freedom
because you know that it's just like one
of your neighbors doing target practice
in the yard yeah think about it so it's
different
think about it this way if you are in an
area
where guns are and you know what people
are doing with the guns
you're not worried right people like you
know they're they're shooting at the
range
in the mountain you know shooting it you
know with it with a really great
backstop
and if you're in a big city and you hear
car noises you're fine now imagine this
you're in the middle of nowhere on top
of a mountain there's no roads anywhere
for like 15 miles
and you hear cars driving around you're
gonna freak out right like if you're in
your cabin in the woods on your property
it's like a you know
20 acres or something in the middle of
nowhere or you're on some resort
and you hear cars driving around and
there's no roads you'll probably wake up
like what is going on you'll freak out
imagine if you were you know vacationing
somewhere in a private community and
then you hear
a weird noise that doesn't belong
doesn't matter if it's car or otherwise
same thing is true for guns
when you're in dc and you know the only
reason people are shooting us because
they're criminals it's going to freak
you out yeah
i mean and it's weird because it's kind
of backwards for me now i live on like a
dead end road
so when i hear cars i get freaked out
but when i hear gunshots i'm like oh
it's just you know the neighbors even my
liberal neighbors will sit on their
front lawn
we have like one semi-liberal house in
the community and
even they sit out there and they'll like
shoot off their porch and stuff
i mean they're more they're probably
libertarian but whatever
they're more left than the majority of
people on our street but um
when i hear a car go by i'm always like
what the heck is that and then i'm like
oh it's just a dump truck but we don't
even have like mail
that comes to the house because i'm so
far out there yeah so when a car comes
up i'm like
who the heck what's going on but when i
hear gunshots i'm just like oh
yeah yeah i remember i was walking
through this area in west virginia
and i heard gunshots going off and i'm
like i gotta find out where those are
and i'm walking towards the sound oh my
god
you know why because the people who are
there shooting aren't insane people
they're not shooting randomly into the
woods and it's not hunting season
so i know that as long as you know i'm
i'm
if i'm gonna make my way to these people
i know they're probably target shooting
because i was told specifically by a
store that they do target shooting
i'm hearing this then i know they're
they're very very likely
practicing safety and i'm not worried
about them
it's it's just like when i'm driving
crossing the street i'm not worried
about a car crashing into me
i know that i can i see the car i don't
try making cars break for me when i when
i cross the street you know what i mean
like if you're if you have a crosswalk
i'll try to like run across
quickly but i'm not worried they're
going to slam the gas on and try and
you know steer into me i know it's not
going to happen they don't want to do
that
so when i hear shots in the middle of
nowhere i know there's a range nearby
i'm like
i'm not worried that someone's going to
have an accidental discharge these
people are out a range they're shooting
i'm gonna keep following the noise and
then i end up finding the range and
there's a guy
an older guy and he was you know zeroing
in his sights for his you know hunting
rifle of some sort
and i was like hey howdy and he's like
hey how's it going he's like oh we're
about done here it's all yours i'm like
hey nice to meet you and that was it
yeah that's regular people so how are
you guys familiar with
the story of switzerland and how they do
their guns no
i was reading about them and they start
to train their kids to shoot when
they're very young this is culturally
acceptable
they go to these shooting clubs boys it
used to be a boys only thing now boys
and girls do it
um from my understanding they did have
like a mandatory military service
everyone has a gun zero murder rates
everyone treats them responsibil
responsibly and i i caught a little bit
of heat on twitter for saying this but i
think that gun should be viewed
not as a toy but as something that is
fun and recreational
worthy of respect a tool something
important that we need to understand and
like really grasp
i think that's what we're missing we
need to make it like a cultural norm for
guns to be acceptable
because if we don't they're just going
to be terrifying and only bad people are
going to have them
we're getting we're getting dull like
dull in color and dolan sharpness
people used to die all the time it was
crazy it was crazy
yeah people would have like 10 kids
because half of them would die i was
just telling you guys about that
that siege of in crete where it was a 21
year
siege where kids were born into this
city that was under siege
and they till 21 and they would dig
tunnels i mean
their life was they would go under in
tunnels they couldn't see a guy from me
to you
and they'd have knives or like bats and
try and kill each other in these tunnels
and lay mines and blow i mean it's just
horrible dude horrible this was like 500
years ago
this is i'm glad we don't do that
anymore well i know and thank god
but like if we're not careful it could
degrade back to that like that's why i'm
studying this stuff like
how do we survive if society collapses
oh you build mines under the opposing
uh fence and then you yikes it's crazy
dude
and like tunnel rats in vietnam that
would climb down into the mud
and climb in this like the suffocation
was a constant threat
just the the terror and horror of war
and we have grown soft to that stuff
to everyone no so it's like what's
happening now is
these these cultists are coming in
they're taking over and
it's a really weird thing like i don't
understand this weird overlap between
the liberals the left and wokeness
because they're a bunch of hard leftists
like dsa
they're as woke as woke can be to the
point where it's actually horrifying
like that video where the guy's like
hello my name's toby he him i just like
to say a you know point of point of
privilege um
the chatter in this room is really
making it hard for me to focus everybody
guys you need to calm down and the
person goes stop saying
guys and don't and i'm like this is just
lunacy
they couldn't even have a cohesive
meeting you know so i'm i'm wondering
where's that then there's like the dirt
bag left
that are pro-gun anti-woke and just
socialists
so i'm like what's this overlap so are
these cultists
are they socialists the people who are
coming in doing critical race theory in
these schools
or are they just woke cultists you know
what i mean
they're like um or they're opportunists
yeah i think they're marxists
so they're like all about redistribution
of the
means of production or what yeah and
they're also on a power trip a lot of
this i think
isn't even political necessarily i think
that some people got bullied in high
school and now they want to get back at
the world by bullying
everybody else i honestly think that a
lot of it
is not political i think that it's just
power it's a cult yeah that's all it is
and that's why i was saying earlier it's
like the rules
don't exist they change on a whim
because the real goal is that there's a
the real issue is that there is a
chaotic destructive force that just
seeks to infect and destroy and it has
no real goals like think about what the
woke stuff is doing
what is it doing it's vengeance
destroying businesses
yeah it's just corroding culture and
destroying
enterprises and business people want to
be avengers in real life they want to
they want to
avenge their past torture from being
bullied i know because i went through it
in 2006 i started making youtube videos
i was like wow
if i want to destroy anyone right now i
could get a crowd of people
to go destroy their lives not not
physically but just
basically it was pre-cancelled culture
pre-docs pre all that stuff
but i realized how powerful it was this
ostracization and how
humiliation of people i could use
because i'd like 10 000
people would watch and i'd be like yo
call this guy on this day
everyone call him at this time and let
him know this this information
and then do it let's do it again
tomorrow and like i the power of the
crowd
it was and i so i i didn't allow myself
to fall thank god
think about it this way you said the
avengers marvel movies were amazing
making tons of money everybody really
likes them and they started getting a
little woke
and then people started complaining a
little bit you know their black panther
got some heat which i don't think was
entirely undeserved but i like black
panther i give it a 7 out of 10.
captain marvel got roasted and it
absolutely deserved it now they all made
a ton of money don't get me wrong
but it's like that was the
biggest cultural institution we had
in film like the marvel movies are each
movie's over a billion dollars
event end game was like the biggest
movie for a while i guess avatar got
re-released
and then they infect it and infect it in
fact infect it with
this cult that starts just destroying
what makes it interesting
then you start seeing you know some of
the moves that come out are not as good
and the riding gets a little weaker and
it's like
eating at the base of what makes things
fun and interesting and slowly eroding
and destroying them it creates nothing
it does nothing that's why i think
marxism makes sense these people want to
completely destroy
what culture there is to create a new
one they want to they want to erase it
first so they're not producing anything
they're going to destroy everything and
then from the from the ashes they will
try to build anew
i'm not familiar enough with marxism um
like communism like china is like a
pseudo
or like a neo communist it's not a real
communist state it's like
it's just totalitarianism yeah it's a
weird like amalgamation of communism and
capitalism and
and so there probably is a new word for
it maybe what these people are doing is
a new word for like a neo marxism
i i would say it's fair to say real
communism has never been tried
and then you must add the caveat to that
because every single time someone does
try to do or i'm sorry i'm sorry no
that's wrong real communism has never
been implemented and the issue is that
every time real communism is tried
they end up just killing tons and tons
of people millions of people
and so that says to me that every single
time you try
you will not be able to successfully
implement your utopian vision of
full-on communism it's a feature yeah
well so the general ideas people have
and that's why they don't believe
that they ignore the history is they're
like gotta keep trying gotta keep trying
they have this this magic view that
we're all gonna live in a utopia that
we're all just going to be holding hands
and singing under a rainbow
and then everyone will own everything
and it's just garbage nonsense fairy
tales
so then someone says i'm going to try
and do it hello good sir ian
i'm going to make a communist utopia as
we've all dreamed would you like to join
yes or no
absolutely cassandra would you like to
join my communist utopia
sure you would lydia would you yes
congratulations none of you have to die
wait i haven't i'm having second
thoughts
oh i've got a glock nine millimeter here
not about this oh it's too late
now there's no one left to oppose my
utopian vision
that's exactly what happens every time
it doesn't work because people say
two words i disagree
well i'm gonna have to kill you i guess
so i mean that's essentially what
they're doing to people like digitally
now
they're making it so people can't get
jobs they can't get bank accounts i mean
they're they're effectively like trying
to kill people
that's what i mean that's why it just
becomes authoritarianism
yeah you know you call it fascism if you
want and the left says well
the move actually i don't care what you
want to call it doesn't matter it's a
bunch of
psychopathic violent morons who are
going to destroy
everything because they want power
they're not smart enough to make a
machine work so they're going to throw a
wrench in it
you need some authority like obviously a
local level of authority you need a
sheriff maybe you don't need a sheriff
these days but
seems like you need a local order sure
but top down
authority is very dangerous that's the
path that's the last lesson i've learned
i was talking to
this anarchist dude about how in like
was it uh
uh acapulco is it marco poco not an
archipelago
yeah yeah uh it's very anarchistic
and you know that's what they do and
archipoca and i and i was like
this guy's telling me he's like look
where i live there's no government
there's no police there's no law and
everyone gets along just fine
and i was like so what would happen if
you like walked into your neighbor's
house and took his stuff
he's like i'd probably shoot me i'm like
oh because you have a general
understanding about what isn't isn't
acceptable right
of course so people work and i was like
listen
the the general understanding of what is
or isn't acceptable is the basic
formation of government between people
a social order that exists so you're not
in
okay fine i get it you call it anarchy
and there's no authority so
and without archie authority that i
understand but there is government
people are armed and so let me ask you
another question if
someone comes into your house and takes
your stuff would your neighbors help you
stop that person yes congratulations you
formed a small government
that there's no exchange of of of of of
currency
you just agree we live here we're in
charge and if someone comes and tries to
take from us we're going to use force
against them
scale that up and you get more and more
government so it's really simple to
start creating government
and then you take a look at these small
anarchist communities and it's no
surprise that over time as more people
move in
government becomes more and more
overbearing so i actually was thinking
about this in terms of science
and i feel like it's basically following
a similar principle to
the uh um the state of matter so i think
about it this way
you have gas particles are really are
far apart bouncing around all crazy and
so it makes this
you know the gas can be you know moved
and shifted about and you can whiff
through it and all that stuff
as you start to compress that into a
tighter and tighter space becomes liquid
now it's harder to move through and then
if you compress it even further it
becomes a solid now you can't move
through it at all
that's basically how i view government
if you have a bunch of people all
separated
then they have these big bubbles of
inherent of personal freedom where they
can do whatever they want
we can go outside and launch our remote
control car 50 feet up in the air and
laugh as it smashes into the ground you
can't do that in new york
it'll come and get angry because the
closer people get together
it starts becoming rigid like solid
matter people's rights get compressed as
more people emerge around them
and then big cities start pushing
totalitarian and despotic
rules and laws can't have guns anymore
you can't play loud music
you can't you know play you can't play
play instruments in your own home
you you can't go out at certain points
oh no there's a pandemic now everyone's
gotta get shots and everyone's gonna get
vaccine passports
then you go to the mountain where
everyone's separated life's normal
yeah make totally free we're also
unincorporated too
so we don't even have like that much
government really i mean obviously we
have like state and
county and stuff but we don't i mean
people will be in our group chat being
like hey is this legal
and people will respond and be like is
somebody gonna die
and then they'll be like no and they're
like okay then do it what are we going
to do like i mean
that's that's that's so we had a
conversation about guns uh with luke
and we were talking about how like in
new york city for instance it's like
almost impossible to have a gun
and then you get all these liberals
being like why would anyone need an
ar-15
and it's like you're not even saying
anything when you say that because
there's so many different variants and
like
calibers and and modifications just like
you don't know what you're talking about
but i mentioned you know it's probably
not a good idea for someone to have
a 308 you know rifle
for home defense in a studio condo
in new york city because that bullet's
going to rip through
walls and maybe hit somebody and then
luke instinctively
said maybe we restrict and i was like
what do you get no no no the point is
maybe the individual is responsible for
whatever comes out of the barrel of that
gun
and if they do have a 308 in their home
they should know better than firing it
because it's going to go through walls
and if they hit somebody that's
negligent homicide
because you are the individual
responsible for that weapon should be
allowed to have it but if you shoot it
you're going to get arrested when
someone gets hit or from the vandalism
and damage you caused by doing it
same as if you had a car and you drove
onto private property you're in trouble
so maybe favorite same if you had a car
and you were speeding and you hit
somebody you're legally allowed to have
a car
you're not legally allowed to crash that
car into someone's storefront
so i'm like you know that that's the
idea of individual responsibility in big
cities
you can still have that freedom it's
just your responsibility i really like
this metaphor of
states of matter and government like
constriction like pressure like because
beyond so maybe we're in the fluidic
state it's either liquid or gas there's
resistance when you move
the government is the resistance you can
kind of push through it there's wind
resistance you hit terminal velocity but
once you get even
more spacious than gas you turn into
plasma
which is the fourth state of matter
which is like there is no wind
resistance in a planet people are
running around firing rockets and
they're back
it's electromagnetic yeah what is it
like like plasma
is the fourth state of matter i would
liken that to living
literally in you know 100 square miles
of desert with no one around you
you could just take a dump right there
with access like you need like
electrons can appear in different places
well okay no i don't know about that
like matter formation
i'm just talking about the closer people
come together
their rights start compressing and it
becomes totalitarian like a rigid solid
state
if you need to import resources that's
bringing people closer together so
if you don't need to import resources
and you can create them on the spot
you could take a dump in the desert you
can create your water and your food the
fourth state
that's where we're headed the fourth
state of this analogy is that you're in
the middle of the woods
on this massive 200 acre plot of land
you own
and there's no one who's allowed on your
property and you take a dump right there
in an open field and the only one you
bothered is the guy in the space station
who's looking down with his you know
satellite telescope whatever and he's
like posting it to instagram you know
he's like that's so gross
or he laughs and he's like legit if
people could have lots of space and
could create all their materials on
on source like at on location i think
that we would not really need government
like this you you could you could have
in the middle of nowhere
i mean there's so there still is
population density of the planet which
means
you can't you know build nuclear weapons
and stuff because people
you'll interfere with them at a greater
distance but think about like
your range of effect when it comes to
your rights
if you live in a tiny cubicle apartment
in new york you can't play the drums man
because you're gonna have 10 people
being like dude come on man
it's not fair to us i know that
firsthand right it's and so you're like
i have a right to be noisy
between these hours and it's true but
it's kind of a dick move you know people
might go to sleep they might have a
night shift
so it's not necessarily just about law
it's about social enforcement now you
live in the middle of nowhere 200 acres
you're right in the middle
you could literally pull out like i mean
just watch hickok45
the dude just goes nuts i watched the
video i was tweeting about the ksg25
dude loads ksc25 with slugs it's a
tactical shotgun that holds 25 shotgun
shells
and he's just going boom boom like crazy
just shooting shotgun slugs like nuts
because there's nobody around him and if
you had your own planet
you could set up nukes all over the
planet known as exactly that's the
plasma
you have your own planet like dr
manhattan and he builds a gigantic weird
structure and he floats around doing
whatever he wants because you got
nothing no one to bother and that's
literally you could light off nukes and
no one would care well let's let's
or it wouldn't be concerned thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you